simplifica 2 a cuadrada sobre tres de a
la quinta todo eso elevado a la cuarta y
aquí podemos usar la propiedad que nos
dice que si tenemos x sobre y elevado a
la potencia n esto es igual a x elevado
a la potencia n sobre y elevado a la
potencia n veamos que eso se cumple con
el siguiente ejemplo si tenemos x sobre
y elevado al cubo esto es igual a x
sobre y por x sobre y por x sobre i y
esto es igual a x por x x x dividido
entre sí porque porque y esto es igual a
x cúbica entre sí kubica es un ejemplo
particular muy sencillo pero para que te
des cuenta que esta propiedad se cumple
y la puedas usar con confianza
apliquemos esa propiedad en nuestro
ejemplo aquí nos están dando dos a
cuadrada entre 3 b a la quinta
todo eso elevado a la cuarta esta
expresión la podemos escribir como el
numerador es
a cuadrada elevado a la cuarta lo
escribimos aquí abajo 2a cuadrada
elevado a la cuarta
voy a poner en azul este exponente 42 al
cuadrado elevado a la cuarta dividido
entre 3 ve a la quinta
3b a la quinta elevado a la cuarta
elevado a la cuarta y ahora voy a usar
la propiedad de que si tengo el producto
de dos factores elevado una potencia eso
es exactamente igual a que eleve primero
cada factor a la potencia y luego
realice el producto así es que esto va a
ser igual déjame escribir esa propiedad
por acá si tenemos digamos x por ye
elevado a la n esto es igual a x a la n
por que a la n iv podría desarrollar un
ejemplo similar al que hicimos aquí
abajo para convencerte de esta propiedad
vamos a aplicarlo aquí en nuestra
expresión esto va a ser igual
2 elevado a la cuarta 2 elevado a la
cuarta que multiplica que multiplica a
cuadrada
elevado a la cuarta
y todo eso dividido entre 3 ve a la
quinta elevado a la cuarta lo cual va a
ser 3 elevado a la cuarta 3 elevado a la
cuarta que multiplica a b quinta ve a la
quinta elevado a la cuarta ahora aquí
también hay algo interesante pero vamos
a evaluar los coeficientes primero
tenemos entonces en el numerador es 2 a
la cuarta 2 a la cuarta es 2 al cuadrado
es 4 2 al cubo es 8 2 a la cuarta es 8
por 2 16 vamos a ponerlo aquí esto es 16
y 3 a la cuarta 3 al cuadrado es 9 3 al
cubo es 27 3 a la cuarta es 81 3 a la
cuarta es 81 vamos a escribirlo aquí
déjame hacerlo con otro color voy a
ponerlo con el mismo verde 81 y para
evaluar estas expresiones podemos usar
la propiedad del producto de los
exponentes si tengo un número elevado a
un exponente y a la vez elevado a otro
exponente se hace el producto de los
exponentes veamos
si tenemos x elevado a la potencia n iv
a la vez está elevado a la potencia m
esto es igual a x elevado a la potencia
n + m así es que como queda nuestra
expresión en el numerador tenemos 2 a la
cuarta que ya calculamos que es 16 que
multiplica a al cuadrado elevado a la
cuarta y esto es a la 2 por 4 que es
igual a a la octava esto salió de
multiplicar vamos a ponerlo aquí
multiplicamos 2 por 4 y nos dio el 8 el
exponente y eso dividido entre eso
dividido entre 81 que multiplica a b a
la quinta elevado a la cuarta
esto es b elevado a las 5 por 4 que es b
elevado a la 20 este 20 salió de
multiplicar 5 por 4 hemos concluido la
hemos simplificado a su mínima expresión